je suis jean christian freyssinet des le
fils bodin du doigt des bodin's
qu'est-ce qu'il se passe pas bien
procéder à un licenciement
et puis là j'ai besoin d'aller voir ma
mère alors même en fait j'ai deux mers
j'ai la vraie mère celle qui m'a mis au
monde et maria bodin là je vais voir ma
vraie mère qui était encore pire que
maria belen non je rigole faut pas lui
dire tiens du monde
on est là on est là à il tombe bien
qu'est ce qui t'arrive
ben on est ça va je recherche le on
avait un vieux poste dans le temps
qu'elle était chez dans la maison de mon
oncle un vieux poste de radio les années
leurs voix gillet pas chez moi je
pensais qu'il avait chez moi je le
trouve pas alors je pense qu'il doit
être là c'est vrai c'est pas trop où
exactement
dans tout ce bazar pourtant tu sais bien
où sont les trucs en général chercher
dieu que ça sert de garde est en fait
c'est quand même assez tragique
d'aujourd'hui ce soir parce que voilà la
bête quand on était enfant avec mes
frères et mes parents on a on a
participé beaucoup aux spectacles du
château de valençay donc on a eu quand
on était tout petit on avait une dizaine
d'années mais ferait encore plus petit
donc mes parents participer aussi et
depuis on a toujours participé au
spectacle et mes parents nous suivent
toujours et dans la mesure du possible
voilà dans le prochain spectacle de la
fine équipe qui seront aussi figurant
dans la seine d'exode etc
donc voilà ils sont on les a on les
embarque partout on peut voit nous n'a
choisi de rester à la nôtre pays
d'origine pour vivre de notre métier
donc c'est aussi pour ça qu'on a acheté
la ferme théâtre de bellevue parce que
tout le monde quand on a envie de
devenir comédien les les gens vous
disent il faut aller à paris mais on
peut très bien bien vivre de notre
métier sur place à condition d'avoir des
idées donc alors tout le monde ressort
la ferme de
d'être de bellevue c'est un vrai théâtre
qui fonctionne à l'année on y fait
principalement des repas spectacle mais
on sert aussi de notre lieu pour répéter
d'autres spectacles on a aussi répété
les bodins ici mais on a aussi du décor
même des murs de la ferme pour un
spectacle extérieur que l'on fait tous
les maisons là et le prochain sera la
fine équipe ont cette fois ça y est la
fine équipe est au complet
ah ben tu vois quand même j'ai
l'impression qu'il est pas venu tout
seul parce que tu fous et aux douches
mans les boss est ce que je peut garer
mon vélo sans me faire engueuler merci
tout de suite tu me le récupère ouais
refait juste tu leur dis ça à eux deux
là bas heureusement que son vélo connaît
le chemin vagues et s'est coupée au
mouvement les boss est ce que je peut
garer mon vélo sans me faire engueuler
merci c'est toujours très émouvant de
deux parce que l'écriture c'est assez
solitaire donc d'autant qu'un ça s'est
fait pendant le confinement donc c'était
plus que solitaire donc mais quand on
écrit on est immergé dans son histoire
regardez ces deux belles fleurs que ce
cyclamens voilà tu voi attaque études tu
fais le tour
en fait là pour l'instant on l'a pas
fait coupures dans le texte mais on va
peut-être en faire au fur et à mesure
une petite réplique on se dit tiens ça
c'est moins efficace est ce que ça sert
à quelque chose
hop on l'enlève si ça sert à rien donc
il ya encore énormément d'ajustements à
faire là on est vraiment au tout début
des répétitions donc on est encore le
texte à la main on sait pas très bien le
texte c'est pour dresser intégré chacun
manche je parle à tout le monde parle à
chez lui il ya de l'impatience se sont
beaucoup d'impatience de il s'enferme
sur lui-même et déjà renfermé sur
lui-même alors l'un sociale
si c'est encore pire et tu me sens très
très très impatiente rennes mais là et
tout de suite très inquiètant faut que
la voiture arrive donc vous serez la
voiture elle sera derrière eux
mais avant ces vases il a avancé jusque
dans le milieu la tacc ici arrêtez
arrêtez vous arrêtez vous tu prends le
le panier non non il prend il prend le
panier je pense qu'il aura pas de siège
le panier et toi tu prends la halle et
la nappe
moi je te reverrai toujours le jour où
on a inauguré
et quand il a quand il a regardé quand
il a regardé cette scène il était tout
seul dans son coin tout le monde était
ensemble et puis tout seul dans son coin
puis regarder ça de nerfs de dire ça y
est je les beaux théâtres
je pense qu'il a accomplis sont revus je
pense